show you a sorter red pill yeah and then  that point what made you cross all the  way over to Red Pill well oh I'll tell  you why it was Kevin Samuels was where  kind of started to Red Pill me because  they were talking about high value men  right and they're saying like all high  value men cheat and I was so confused  because my dad's a hot like like because  they listed out the like the things that  they have to beat and it was like my dad  was all of them except LinkedIn because  my dad doesn't have social media but  they they said  um all high value men cheating of  Mistresses so I called my dad I'm like  where are your hoes Dad they said you  gotta have hoes  and so that's what I started watching  which but then um yeah then I just  started watching the content I was like  oh this is interesting